good morning Johnny and George's zombie
list very much though it was woefully
lacking in World War Z which is the only
piece of media that's given me
nightmares since Akira I don't know if
you know this but dad took me to see
Akira when I was 10 in a dinner theater
and I will never forgive him there's a
song that plays during a particularly
creepy part of the movie I'm playing it
for you right now though I'm not
listening to it because if I was
listening to it I would look like this
in my opinion that song is the creepiest
piece of media that has ever been
created John here's what I just did i
just took a copyrighted work and then i
commented on it and that is what we call
fair use because you can't just steal
copyrighted stuff and did like i
monetize it and be like it smiled you
can comment on a copyrighted work and
then that comment can include pieces of
the copyrighted work making that illegal
would be a violation of free speech but
fair use is still a little bit fuzzy
under the law and so the people who
created accurate could come in and
challenge me on that why do you think
that american copyright law needs to be
better love copyright law we need
copyright law John I don't want people
to steal your books but I also do not
want Congress stick in it smarmy dirty
little fingers into my internet I'm
sorry Congress I know you guys get a bad
rap but don't mess with my internet or I
will come at you so John I have a
top-five list for you today it's my top
5 reasons why we should not let Congress
regulate the internet 1 I don't want to
go to jail also I don't want 95% of
people under 30 to be in jail I just I
think it would be really bad for the
American economy if we were all in jail
number 2 one of the current pieces of
legislation is called the preventing
real online threats to economic
creativity and theft of intellectual
property act and I feel like I should be
doing this like a politician I don't
know why they think that this is the
hand motion they should always be and
the name of that act makes me want to
co-sponsor a bill called anti contrived
representations of name yielding
mnemonics and seriously shut up Congress
act 3 anti-piracy legislation stifles
creativity and it stifles economic
growth machinima is a great example of a
very large company doing very well in
this economy basically does things that
are illegal but no one cares that
they're illegal cuz they're actually
good for the copyright holders copyright
holders are happy about copyright
infringement and are
copyright legislation is clearly not to
lack for we cannot blame a site for
content that its users upload think
about tumblr which is made wonderful by
all of the gifts of Abed saying whatever
Abed said last night on community the
protect IP Act would make tumblr
responsible for keeping all of those off
the site and if it was found that they
weren't doing everything they could to
keep those gifts off the site they could
be turned off like a flip of the switch
no more tumblr and finally number five
we really should not be putting the
power into the hands of corporations
here under the protect IP act a
corporation could flag a vlog brothers
video for being in violation of its
copyright the video would then be taken
down without any review by a person to
figure out whether or not it has
copyright infringement we the little
content creators that we are could then
do nothing to get it back online because
apparently the Motion Picture
Association of America is now a law
enforcement body the massive explosion
of good creative content and art and
ideas that has come out of the Internet
is just it's a good thing and we should
not be throwing a wrench into this
process and yes technology is forcing
this change we are being forced to
change but we are going to have to
change trying to lock it down by
screwing up the only really good
economic engine that we have right now
is just everyone check down in the
scription below where i've written some
stuff about how you can help keep the
internet free John I will see you on I
don't know what day what day is it today
is it god yeah I'll see you on Monday
we are having a blizzard